whoever is listening to this you are
more unique and valuable than you think
you are and
everyone is kind of an incredible
combination of their genetics and their
experience and their perspectives and
their beliefs and
everyone is unique and everyone has some
sort of skill or
insight that they can bring to other
people if you can learn it and package
it the right way and just
see what people respond to that you want
to bring to them that's probably even
before
the kind of logistical stumbling blocks
is just the belief that there's
something there for you to do and for
you to add value
eric welcome to the show thanks for
having me i've been excited about this
ever since i listened to you and george
mack [ __ ] around on here i was like
this is gonna be a good time i'm gonna
like this
yeah it's uh it's all a boys club up
here and here isn't it so
today is naval fest 2020
welcome to naval fest 2020 this this big
dick energy we're just marinading in it
today and
we're gonna see how much we can jerk off
over naval over the next 60 minutes
a couple hundred pages probably worth um
and then and then edited material so we
got a lot to go on
dvd extras pay-per-view only fans like
additional content
dvd commentary bonus scenes director's
cut we got it all
i love it so why are you writing a book
about naval why did you
like what makes him worthy of a book who
is he
i've been following naval for 10 years
now maybe
uh he was the first person i kind of got
introduced to in the valley not
personally but
when i was you know just wet behind the
ears kid from michigan who had never
left michigan and was like trying to get
into the startup world somebody's like
go read all adventure hacks follow neval
do everything he says um him and paul
graham were kind of like
those are the lighthouses of the valley
like go listen and follow
um so that i've been kind of following
for a long time and i've learned a ton
from him
and as he's kind of evolved over the
years and started sharing more and more
stuff i've learned more and more
and i found myself recommending you know
his podcast his tweets
and for to more and more people for more
and more reasons and i realize
kind of how hard it is for people
outside of like the twitter
verse and the podcast world to kind of
pick up that and run with it and learn
from it but the stuff that he talks
about
um it can be so life-changing for so
many people at many different stages i
think
and there's just so much value there
that i really wanted like an easy
on-ramp and i wanted a tight package and
i'm watching these like
value you know huge pieces of wisdom
um just kind of slide into the like
twitter nothingness
um and it broke my heart and i'm like i
need to turn this into something more
evergreen something more permanent
and you know there's no better package
than a book everybody knows what to do
with a book
everybody um you know that's easy to
gift it's easy to read through
um it's people know kind of what to do
with it and hopefully it'll live on
you know and stay relevant for a really
long time what's unique about naval
naval i like came to the us as a
poor immigrant at nine years old i think
brooklyn
and just kind of had to start from
nothing and build his way up um
you know he got into a good high school
uh which was which was
a huge turning point for him early in
his life and he's undeniably just
a brilliant guy so um you know he didn't
scrap it together from nothing you know
he's definitely got some like horsepower
um
we got into this great high school got
into dartmouth started at the bottom in
the tech world
uh you know studied computer science and
eventually kind of
through a bunch of different missteps
and adventures and companies and
failures and lawsuits um and investments
kind of found his way into
breaking out in the tech world and
starting angel list
and he's incredibly widely followed kind
of in that tech world for
what he's built there and the
investments that he's made in twitter
and uber and
he's in this kind of interesting chapter
of life that you see kind of a lot of
people go through where they have
achieved all of the successes that they
hope to achieve when they were younger
and they're now kind of both giving back
those lessons of how they achieved what
they did
and kind of turning to philosophy and
family
and legacy and just looking at how they
can how they can give back and how they
can learn
um a little bit more about you know life
instead of the rat race and so it's kind
of an interesting turning point where he
knows a lot about wealth from his past
and you know he continues to work and
invest but he's learning a lot about
happiness um
in the very recent present and is
practicing it currently
and continuing to kind of develop that
and share it the particular
uh interesting insight that i have about
naval the reason i think i'm drawn to
him
is the fact that his wisdom is so
practical
there's part of me uh ryan holiday was
recently on here massimo piglucci's been
on here we've talked a lot about
stoicism and it's like the hot new girl
in school for 2020
but there's part of me when i read it
that
doesn't like how abstract it is all
right man
yeah virtue and integrity and you
overcome the obstacle
i'm like okay i get it but there's
there's just a part of it that feels
too like bourgeois and artsy
you know like let's not forget that the
vast majority of the stoics
came from wealth like there was some
there was some that was born as slaves
and
ended up in good situations but oh bad
situations
but the vast majority of them came from
wealth and i think that even two and a
half thousand years later that still
kind of
reflects and shows on whereas someone
whose
wisdom has really really been not just
designed for practicality but forged in
reality
like naval's is is something that um
attracts me to it particularly and i
think as well the vast majority
of us are you know like middle class
working class or aspiring
underclass and with that in mind
you feel a sense of affinity to someone
who's got that
like zero to hero journey you know as
opposed to it just being
someone armchair philosophizing in this
like
baroque [ __ ] mansion somewhere that
their dad has you know
you get me yeah it is very practical and
it is definitely
i find it easier to listen to
philosophies from somebody who has
passed the tests of reality who is an
operator who has founded companies who
has made investments
and stoicism i totally agree with you
like
it's it's easy to like kind of read it
and be like yeah sure i agree
and then passing the test of reality
like there's a lot of times where it is
does is not practical like it is almost
incompatible with having like
close intimate relationships or
friendships and like i really want to
hear people talk about like
how they act how they react stoically
when like their partner is upset or when
their child is upset
and things like that that are it's not
like a guru on a mountain like it's easy
to be stoic and you're by yourself like
under a tree and that's just not how we
live and not
i don't i think how we want to live um
so finding the kind of like where do you
put the dial between
stoicism as an operating philosophy and
maybe a business practice and
you know how you act with your family
when you need to be empathetic and build
deep relationships and do friendships
um i think that's something that's like
really kind of interesting to dig into
and a
piece of curiosity that i'm left with
even after this book is kind of like
where do you where do you go to kind of
find that balance between the ideal and
the practical
i think that's a really important point
the fact that you can write something
which is 100 artsy and sounds beautiful
in these abstract terms
but there's a lot of work left to be
done by the reader to then deploy that
to their own lives
and i think that again you know this is
just a full-on
jerk off around naval but i think the
reason that he has managed
to resonate with people saying things
that really should be
far too high brow for the everyone to
listen to
um is that he's sacrificed maybe sort of
10 to 20 percent
of the artsyness for an additional 80
of practical um ability to apply
almost immediately you know it reads
like it's somewhere in between
stoic maxims and a how to
put your life together guide if it was
done like by an ikea
uh instruction manual yeah yeah get into
the principles
precisely so look the book is split into
two parts
wealth and happiness are there any
sections that you could have added but
you didn't
oh many yeah um the first manuscript of
this the thing was like
hundreds more pages um and it included
you know his thoughts on blockchain and
education and the future
there was kind of this whole futurism
section and
investing and how to operate startups um
i did one section it was just the story
of angellist
you know how you know the trials that he
went through kind of as an early founder
led to his views on venture capital
which led to
you know venture hacks to blog which led
to angel list the platform it's a really
really incredible story
um all of that is on the website so it
like broke my heart to cut it from the
book and i was like
duh just put on the website people who
want it can after they read the book and
go
kind of get into that stuff um early
readers like
everybody kind of loved one or two of
those sections but not all of them and i
didn't want to publish like a
giant textbook of everything they've
ever said even though it's interesting
to me
um so that's kind of self-serve on the
website but the but the main two
sections
um of the book are our wealth and
happiness and i really think it's
you know there's a lot of books out
there on wealth and there's a lot of
books out there on happiness
and naval is is maybe really interesting
in the fact that he sits
at the corner of those two and
kind of very practically to your point
like
looks at the trade-offs between the two
um something i didn't know until reading
this was that
buddha was a prince he was very wealthy
and so when he
you know he was able to kind of just
leave his family and go off in the woods
and meditate and study
and just kind of learn and become
peaceful and practice this philosophy
um and and so naval is very practical
about like
there's actually like a lot of ways in
which happiness is dependent on wealth
building wealth isn't going to make you
happy but it will certainly
give you the space to study and explore
philosophy and to kind of
not spend your whole life with your head
down in the rat race so he's like
by all means like getting rich is a
perfectly practical
reasonable goal on the way to becoming
happy like you don't have to be happy to
be rich
but also it definitely helps like your
money solves your money problems and
those are problems so if you can solve
that it gives you time and it gives you
space to kind of explore some of these
other things
and that to your point about the stones
like many of the philosophers
that we looked to were either very very
wealthy
or they had so little and had absolutely
nothing and no responsibilities and
you know they had so little that they
could choose to you know basically
become a monk
renounce everything and find happiness
and so if you're only going to go one of
those two directions like
you can go all the way to having nothing
and wanting nothing and eliminate all
your desires
or you can try to get really rich store
up a bunch of that goodwill and give
yourself the space to kind of lower your
desires below your means
but but just know that you know you got
to build that gap in
or you're just always going to be
unhappy it's like when you're on a diet
anyone who's had to do a hard cut before
a holiday knows
if you're on locales everything every
single experience in your life
is flavored with the fact that you're
still a bit hungry and it's like the
same as being
skin if you've not got enough money if
you don't know where the next paycheck
or the next bills are going to come from
you can be having the best time of your
life
but there's this tarnish that's layered
this veneer that sort of layered over
the top of things
that says yeah but but money yeah but
but i don't know where the next paycheck
is coming from and it's
um being rich might not make you happy
but being poor can make you miserable
and diogenes the cynic who lived out of
a pot
and was sort of the first of the
minimalist movement which we're now
seeing a resurgence in and like
asceticism and minimalism
i guess in the 20th century 21st century
um
yeah diogenes was like the the
grandfather of that
but i don't want to be diogenes you know
like i want to have
nice things i want to and again another
novelism which everyone will be familiar
with one of my favorites is
it is far easier to achieve your
material desires than it is to renounce
them so i would much sooner say i don't
need a ferrari when my last car was a
ferrari
then try and battle through all of the
different
bizarre attachments that i've got to
work out yeah but i never wanted it in
any case and you get into so much sort
of self-deception there in any case
so okay wealth how is wealth created
yeah wealth is created um there's a
whole kind of
set of formulas in the book that kind of
break this down almost almost
uh principal formulas and so your income
is determined by
your accountability plus your specific
knowledge plus the degree of leverage
that you're using and then your income
is going to determine your wealth based
on your savings rate
and your return on income but naval
really prioritizes
building wealth as uh looking for assets
that can earn money while you sleep
so building media buying equity in a
business
you have to get sort of you know whether
you're building software whether you're
building
a podcast or a blog or a book or
whatever it is
do something that can work that is not a
linear input and output
you know if you're working even if
you're a very high paid doctor
you're working an hour you're getting
paid even a thousand ten thousand
dollars an hour it's gonna be really
really
tough to outwork the amount of time that
you have and so you have to start using
tools of leverage so labor capital
um or product in order to kind of build
in that leverage and get that
compounding going because it's gonna
take you a long time and you're going to
need
that compounding relationship with a
long
period of time probably in order to
actually
get the space to build that wealth
that particular insight which comes from
the e-myth
revisited as well that if you have any
business
where if you were to leave for more than
six weeks and the whole thing was to
fall apart
that's not a business that's just a
highly leveraged job
that insight to a lot of people you know
especially if you've grown up working
class
you know i own my own business i'm or
even what what's a synonym for that
i'm my own boss okay
i'm my own boss and i own a business are
two
incredibly different things you talked
about um
accountability and some other terms that
are very like navali
can you just break those down for people
who haven't gone down the rabbit hole
already
yeah sorry i went through a lot kind of
quickly there um
and the book is really an attempt to
unpack a lot of those terms and so you
know it's easy to kind of blow through a
few words but
really like accountability is a
compression of pages and pages of
ideas uh same with specific knowledge
specific knowledge is probably the right
place to start so
specific knowledge is kind of finding a
fit between
what society needs what the world is
willing to pay for
and what you are uniquely capable of
and happy to deliver as a work product
right
so you love talking about modern wisdom
philosophers
stoicism talking with people on the
internet
and pulling out their lessons and
sharing it with people you're really
good at it you're passionate about it
you love to do it
and that is going to let you outwork and
outpace and outperform a lot of other
people that might try to do it but not
be
as not have it be in quite as good of
alignment
with who they are as a person and what
they've spent their whole life studying
and becoming
and so that specific knowledge is really
um there's kind of two parts and one is
understanding yourself
well enough to know what your talents
are and what you really want to be doing
and that is
that is not to be overlooked like that
is a hard thing to do um
and it's something that we are all kind
of you know we're always changing and
our understanding of ourselves are
always changing
and growing and so you know relying on
the people around you um they actually
may be better at
showing you kind of who you are and what
your specific knowledge and skills are
one of the tests that uh questions at
neval asked is like what are the things
that other people ask you to do
you know what what are things that
people come to you for help with um
or what are the things that you found
yourself doing at a very young age
like your your parents and those around
you like you know the things that you've
been doing since you if you were a
gossip
you know in third grade and you're
running around tattling on people like
maybe you're
a journalist now or something you know
um
so that's one piece the other piece of
that specific knowledge is getting to
understand what you can deliver to
society that they are the society is not
yet able to get for itself um or that
you might be able to do better than
anyone has ever done it before
and hopefully at scale back to what we
were
talking about i'm like you don't want
inputs and outputs on an hourly basis
you want to be able to do something that
is going to be you know
replicable 10 times or 100 times or a
thousand times whether that's through
media or code or you know labor or
capital what are some examples of those
four types of leverage
just in real world yeah so
capital um is maybe the easiest place to
start
um because if you place a bet for ten
dollars you buy a stock with ten 10
and you're right and it doubles it goes
to 20 but if you do it with a million it
goes to 2 million
and the rewards for that are the
leverage comes from capitals this exact
same decision
but if you make the decision leveraged
by capital that is a huge
outcome differential um and so you can
use your own capital
certainly like there's a lot of leverage
that comes from that but there is also
capital from others and
for that you need to be able to kind of
build your reputation and to do that
you're taking accountability in public
so you that accountability
for your bets and making publicly kind
of
um observable things so that you can
build that track record of having good
judgment
so that other people are willing to kind
of lend you their leverage in the form
of capital or in the form of labor
so labor is another piece where um you
know there's a there's an amazing design
for you know an automobile at tesla but
it takes
hundreds thousands of people to build
that car to that spec
and that is you know every person who's
working under that plan is a piece of
that
leveraged outcome like labor is a is a
form of leverage there's you know
someone can perform a task for a hundred
dollars an hour and that company is
going to pay them
50 an hour to do it but it's worth 100
to the market so there's leverage
in that um and you want to be you know
by owning the equity of that business
you are on
the profiting side of that leverage
instead of the like slightly
less profiting side of that leverage not
that it's not a you know a positive
trade for both because
people need jobs and employment and pick
up skills and everything like that you
know everybody's
starts there at some point but hopefully
by buying equity in that business
so that's a that's a piece that he talks
about as well there's a lot of ways to
get equity
but the people who get truly wealthy
almost always do it through
equity ownership so those the first i
guess those are kind of the traditional
two
and then we've got media and is it
programming or code
or product he says uh it's a little bit
of a mouthful but the full kind of
definition
is products with no marginal cost of
replication
um yeah code code
[Laughter]
code and media uh jim o'shaughnessy
actually he refers to it as
symbol manipulation which i think is
kind of interesting um
like broad classification uh but like
includes podcasts like what we're doing
right now is we record it once you know
we spend two hours on it
but it lives on forever you know whether
100 people listen to it or a hundred
thousand people listen to it
like that value is still there and it
can be available and served up even when
we are not there to you know talk to
people it's not like we have to have
this conversation
over and over again on demand every time
that someone decides to do it
yeah they pull open their podcast app
and say i want to listen to chris and
eric and we
ah eric mate someone's done it again
we're gonna have to wake up
what did i say i can't remember how we
started so it's that and then it's i'm
talking about
the code so how would code work what
would be an example of that
yeah that's you know someone writes a
software program um
that one person could buy or 100 people
could buy or a thousand people could buy
and there's you know server farms all
over the world that can
dish it out to people and that program
may need to be updated and kept relevant
but once it runs
um a thousand people can buy and that's
why we're seeing like enormous margins
in in software and sas um which is
really a thing that you know
didn't exist in the industrial era so
the
the marginal cost of replicating some of
these solutions is just lower than it
has ever been and it completely changes
the economics of some of these
businesses in ways that are really
really interesting
um i think we're still kind of seeing
what the impact of that is
and it i don't know it's gonna be really
interesting um
how this it's still evolving it's gonna
be really interesting i think how it
looks in a historical context and how
we're gonna feel about it but
it accounts for this abundance of of
media and software and things that we
see around us
and the other thing i would say about
the productized piece that is important
is that
they are permissionless right so the
internet is this giant meritocracy where
anyone can record a podcast and push it
out into the world
and only the best ones are going to get
listened to and surfaced and the
audience is going to kind of
let that continue to snowball but no one
can stop you from recording a podcast
there's no editor there's no
there's not a huge capital requirement
no one can stop you from
you know submitting open source code on
github and getting it out there no one
can stop you from getting a gumroad
account and you know starting to kind of
sell things on the internet
so there's there's a key element here
where
the cost of starting something or
getting something out and putting your
entry into this meritocracy
has never been lower and the rewards for
doing it are
basically uncapped if you do it well
enough
that particular section there is
something that everyone listening
probably should go back and listen to
especially if you're new to this concept
i appreciate that for guys like yourself
who's sort of just
bathing in silicon valley and the sort
of wisdom of the
um highly leveraged that it might just
now be taken as
for granted but the vast vast vast
majority of people
even in the western world don't see
work or finances or the route to wealth
in that sort of a way it's a lot more
linear than exponential like that it's
i work at a business i become better at
the business i get
paid more per hour you know if you were
to say to someone hey man
you can have a job that pays you 500
pounds an hour
thousand dollars an hour or whatever
like
unbelievable um but then if you were to
say
you can create a course that teaches
everyone on the planet how to do that
thing that can earn them 500 pounds
or a thousand pounds an hour you could
make 10 grand
every like every couple of hours
well i don't understand like i'm just
doing the same job no no no it's about
abstraction it's about being able to do
stuff at scale it's about being able to
leverage yourself
um and that's something that naval says
he says
is it productize yourself yeah that's
like the summary of the entire tweet
storm is productize yourself
and it for me it took a few passes
through to kind of
understand and be able to unpack or
repack
all of those concepts back into just the
two words productize yourself
but i think there's a few people that
kind of um are
living this in a way that is even
teaching you know i've spent a lot of
time with this material like i like to
think i get the concepts
um but watching guys like jack butcher i
don't know if you
you follow him at all yes
yes they are um and he uh so he
contributed the illustrations for the
book uh so if you love the illustrations
you love jack butcher whether you know
it or not
and he's done an absolutely masterful
job of
productizing himself and creating assets
and courses and products and teaching
people how to visualize
ideas this this incredible skill that
he's developed over
you know years of working with fortune
500 companies and top-tier agencies and
things like that he's a he's incredibly
skilled at it
and he is turning that into
an incredible business and an incredible
kind of um
way to give back to the audience and
help other people like accumulate this
skill
that has been so valuable i mean for me
just to help kind of inculcate these
ideas into my head like being able to
visualize them simply
really carries a lot of weight when
you're working with things that are like
a little bit abstract like this
can you use jack just briefly as an
example between what he was doing as the
agency
with the one problem one solution to
what he's doing now
i think that would be really wonderful
way to sort of just bookend and
illustrate what we've gone through so
far
yeah i'll do my best um i don't know the
story incredibly well
um and if you haven't had him out again
i'm sure he'd be an amazing
guest at some point um to tell his own
story but i'll
butcher the butcher's story the best i
can nice um so
he was working for uh you know some
high-class
agency that was billing him out at you
know thousands of dollars an hour and
he's
a very talented designer and so he was
working you know building logos websites
and things
for you know fortune 500 companies and
have high-end fancy car companies and
stuff like that
and was just getting his ass kicked i
think regularly at work and looking
around i was like
i'm creating a ton of value and a ton of
people are kind of taking their scrape
along the way
and so he started his own agency to kind
of try to recapture some of that
and that was like going well but he was
in that kind of linear trap we were
talking about where he was billing out
he was working his face off and he was
just like man i don't know how i'm gonna
like
get ahead with this um and so he started
kind of stealing time away from himself
to kind of
start working on products and so he
started with the visualized value i
think the daily digest or the daily
manifest was the first
product that he came out with it was
really this
kind of set of questions and um
resources for you to kind of go over
your goals and
work work through this little worksheet
every morning to kind of keep you
focused and keep you focused on the high
leverage things
and did well with that and kind of
layered that up into selling a
little bit more um of a community kind
of product to get people together
and that now i think his kind of
flagship piece is
um build twice build once sell twice
um which is this like productization
playbook and so he sold
courses on how to visualize your ideas
and courses on how to productize
yourself
basically um and it the business is
going gangbusters
you know follow him on twitter and he's
very open about his numbers
um it's really been an incredible thing
to watch just in the time of
you know the last two years while i was
writing this book he was busy applying
the lessons from it and
he made a better use of the last two
years
from a financial perspective but
yeah um him a follow check it out he's a
great guy so that
that little story there hopefully really
drills home the point that we're talking
about here that you have
even someone who's highly talented
and highly remunerated already working
within a business
but there's a glass ceiling on firstly
how much you can earn
plus the freedom that you have etc etc
um
and that is because as you said that
scraping off the top that happens
you get billed out five grand for a day
but your bosses take fifty percent of
that and then there's
that and then you walk away with a grand
and a half which is still a lot but it's
nowhere near as much as you could have
got
plus you're still constrained by working
for someone and not being able to take
time off whenever you want
and then there's a kind of a diagonal
upward and sideways move which is
to owning your own company then you
could start to leverage a little bit
with regards to the labor you could get
you could perhaps be the face of it you
could be the ambassador the one who has
the
gravitas and is well known and then put
designers in underneath you so you don't
necessarily have to do as much grunt
work but even that you can only onboard
as many clients as you have time to fly
to meet them to
the fortune 500 the tesla company
whatever it might be
is what we're going to do for your
design right now i pass it back down
endless meetings back and forth
as opposed to saying right okay i can
conceptualize and wrap up into a
course all of the stuff that i know on
how to be the person
who can do all of the things that are up
to this point and even this point
i will teach you how to make a course
that's exactly like this course using
whatever specific knowledge you have
and that will continue to sell and once
you've written that
that is exactly his build once sell
twice
or build once sell [ __ ] 200 000 times
or whatever is going on at the moment if
i could buy stocks in jack butcher i
would do it um
so that's i think a really really
interesting insight into wealth and
there'll be a lot of people
who hopefully will go and read the book
and it'll make a little bit more sense
but that's such a huge red pill to
swallow like to actually be able to
understand exactly
how you um start to move away from just
time for money at that one for one
and then start to really really leverage
it's a really big
uh really big sort of orthogonal shift
for a lot of people
it is and it's very um it's very
counter-intuitive it's very
like difficult for humans to kind of get
in their head in the same way that it's
difficult for us to intuitively do
the math on compounding and understand
like how things compound and how the
obstacle returns work
let me let me jump in there and i'll let
you continue um
95 of warren buffett's wealth was
created
after his 65th birthday you know that
one
yeah it's incredible and there's not
many people who do
basically two full careers in their
lifetime right like that guy
um it's it's wild and it's one of those
things that doesn't sound right and it
can't possibly be true and you look at
the graphs and it doesn't even make
sense
uh but that's the power of compounding
right and so
that compounding kind of works in all of
these areas and i think leverage is
another
like i'm not very like mathematically
inclined so i might need to
like enlist some help from somebody to
get this but um there is probably in the
same way that you can like
look at a compounding chart and be like
that is [ __ ] mind-blowing like
there's no way that should work but it's
how it works when you just give it the
time
i i think there's something similar with
leverage that it's just so difficult to
intuit that you have to kind of
see it in action and it the same way it
takes time
to to work and build and these things
build on each other um
it's a thing it's probably the thing i'm
most interested in digging into
more after having finished this book
it's it's a thing that
once it got labeled as leverage and of
all categorize it into those kind of
three
broad classes of leverage i started to
think about it completely differently
and i think it's a huge
um it's a hugely improved label on
whatever like now that i know that
there's a thing there i want to go dig
into it and i want to study it and
there's probably
books and like courses and things to do
like a leveraged checklist i'm like how
are you being leveraged and how are you
not and where are you
doing five dollar an hour tasks where
you should be outsourcing that and doing
10 000
an hour tasks um i think there's a lot
to explore there and i'm kind of excited
to kind of go down that rabbit hole
i agree and i think that having as many
practical examples as we can guys like
jack butcher i've taken
inspiration from him myself and i've
been quite transparent with the
reach and the plays of this show it's
not often that you have an objective
measure of anything
you know like success or impact or
happiness or
you know money is like one of the few
things and body weight like that's it
like money and you know how fat you are
and how rich you are and that's it
but um yeah it's it's good to have that
thinking i was just going to say that i
feel like your your former athlete
responds to like give me a scoreboard
and i'm going to
[ __ ] win yes i mean gamifying
gamifying stuff is such a hack as well
the fact that we we struggle with these
abstractions we're not very good at
tracking things
not anyone that's tried to lose weight
without using myfitnesspal like you know
that but you know the pain of like how
many calls was that i
was probably this and you get you gain
you're supposed to be on a hard cut you
feel like you've been on a hard cut and
you've
you've gained weight you know what the
what what happened like you need to
measure absolutely everything exactly
exactly exactly
um how can we prioritize and focus
um prioritizing focus is kind of the um
capstone on the building wealth section
and it really
it does its best to kind of push aside
all the things that are not
specifically about building wealth um so
one of the things
he he kind of looks at is that there's a
lot of people
who are out there trying to kind of
build status um
and they are they build status by
attacking people playing wealth games
and there's like this social hierarchy
game that we are all kind of playing in
this
how we're perceived game that we're all
kind of playing um
but that is not even for most people how
wealth is created you know maybe if
you're a media
person or like an actor there's an
exception to that but for the most part
like
getting rid of all of the things that
are distractions from that and
understanding like where wealth truly
comes from
leverage accountability specific
knowledge building or buying equity in a
business
and just letting that compound you know
getting getting the
you know you're making sure that you are
making incremental progress
and making sure that it's being
reinvested appropriately and then just
giving it time and patience to compound
like focusing on the right stuff
um you know there's there's always a
kind of debate about hard work and hard
work is important
but the thing that comes before hard
work is making sure you are prioritizing
the high leverage work
that's going to give you results over
the long term and focusing on it
and if you're working hard on the wrong
thing you're not going to get anywhere
so getting that getting your priorities
straight which is really
you know by the time you're 50 pages
into the book you should understand what
your priorities are
you know for you today maybe it's
recording this podcast maybe it's
you know publishing something that you
did a week ago there's probably if you
write your whole to-do list there's
probably two things
that are the most critical you know
you're either building leverage
or pushing it out and and kind of
pulling money in so that you can
reinvest that um
and everything else is kind of like
either a low value task or if it got
pushed to tomorrow is fine or somebody
else can pick it up for you
you know one of the things that um naval
uses as a test for this is putting a
really really high hourly value on your
time
so i think he he said today on twitter
that
somebody asked him like so how do you
value your time you said 100
a minute six grand an hour if i can
outsource it
or not do it and it costs me less than
100 a minute
i don't do it and the pushback for that
is people are like
yeah sure but like you're already rich
he's like i don't know i started that
well before i started that when people
would say i should have taken a
20 an hour job or something right um but
having that mindset that like
your time is really valuable and you
have to invest it in those high leverage
tasks
those those key priorities and you've
got to focus on those
that's um kind of a mental tool that you
can use to keep focused on that
and be sure you're working on the right
stuff that's going to going to keep that
compounding engine going
that's another thing as well people
especially if you're working
class working class background like
myself you know mum and dad always
cleaning the house consistently or
or washing the cars mowing the grass
outside
all that sort of stuff it took um my
first ever
boss actually the first ever franchise
that i got for nightlife
um was the guy who owned carnage and
he was a megalomaniac
but had some really great insights and
one of them was precisely this that if
you can outsource something for less
than you charge your timer it wasn't
quite as insightful as naval's
setting yourself this very very high um
price but if you can at the very least
pay someone to do a thing
for less than you charge your time out
for what are you doing
like just go go to work unless you
particularly have
one of these guys who absolutely adores
washing the car which i am
i don't get i just for some people maybe
but not for me not for me and like
cutting the grass is the same thing
what are the other stumbling blocks
that you think people fall over on the
way to this
um end goal of of achieving wealth so
we've talked about the fact that people
get
kind of tied up doing low value tasks
they trip over that and
if you do sufficient low value tasks
today is a i've just been
absolutely submerged in low value tasks
today
but i haven't made the pivot to get a va
or a pa
so i it was either like
don't do them or that everything comes
crumbling down because it's little bits
admin tasks that are necessary
but could be done by someone else what
are some of the other places that people
stumble over
yeah i mean i think that like death by a
thousand cuts of like you feel like
it's one decision at a time of like i'll
just do this it'll be easier to just do
this than get somebody else to do it
because it is an intimidating thing to
go hire somebody even like
you know va or pa for relatively low
amount of money
um it's still like a big gnarly task
when like a clear simple task is in
front of you you can just do it and be
done
um i i think um i think people
underestimate maybe how valuable their
specific knowledge is
or how unique they are um
that's something that is kind of
we all have you know self-doubts and
insecurities and we are like you know
we're used to walking down the street
and feeling not too dissimilar from 10
000 other people that we saw these
success stories and it feels so
maybe far away and like those people
were so different than us
um but it's not like i think everyone
has something really
valuable to bring and can productize
themselves in an interesting way and
everyone's
story can be valuable to someone
um anything is a hell of a drug
yeah it's a hell of a drug and i would
say like
no matter how small you start like jack
again has an
amazing cure for this his goal is just
like make one dollar on the internet
just go sell one thing to one person for
one dollar
and you will feel different it will
start that snowball and you kind of
slowly build up the confidence you know
you got to start at the tutorial level
maybe
um but you're going to keep building
that confidence and you're going to
slowly kind of
grow your way into finding your audience
and find your way through that maze
and just taking that first step will
give you the confidence to take the
second to take the third
um but but you you know whoever is
listening to this that you are more
unique and valuable than you think you
are
and everyone is kind of an incredible
combination of their
genetics and their experience and their
perspectives and their beliefs
and everyone is unique and everyone has
some sort of skill or insight that they
can bring to other people
if you can learn it and package it the
right way and just
see what people respond to that you want
to bring to them
um so that's you know that's probably
even before
the kind of logistical stumbling blocks
is just
the belief that there's something there
for you to do and for you to add value
we're all an expert in something man
like absolutely let's say that you're a
mother
of uh you've been a full-time mother
since you were
23 and you've had you've got this huge
family maybe you've even adopted a
couple of children as well
and you've got now taken
eight infants either your genetics or
someone else's and got them to adulthood
without anything
catastrophic happening you are an
absolute
expert in rearing children this is how
you can manage getting them ready for
school this is how you can manage doing
food prep on a morning
like i know that these especially the
unsexy things like the domestic
side the um relationship side of stuff
that's more to do with
um not just finding a new partner but
actually
further entrenching and improving your
existing relationship
then that's not that sexy you know no
one no one thinks that i'm gonna get
rich on
dealing with the practicalities of
having a big family and making a sas
course about it
but there is a huge huge huge market for
it
and what you're seeing now here's
something that i've got a little bit of
a fear about which is that
the disparity in
work required to produce an online
course versus to produce a book
and the remuneration that you get from
producing an online course versus
producing a book
and now bifurcating so aggressively
that we're going to be swimming in
courses the fact that james clear didn't
just do atomic habits unteachable
is you know beyond me but he decided oh
let's use this
archaic old like stupid form of
communicating something and print it on
paper and maybe you can get it on kindle
and i'll speak it in a
but i i'm you know i hope that
something happens to at least even the
balance out because i know
for a fact that i have tons and tons of
people that i've seen on the internet
who couldn't write a book if their life
depended on it but are killing it in
making online courses or you're teaching
people to do stuff
and everyone knows the same with the
instagram influencer who managed to get
clout online
and he's now monetizing off the back of
one thousand dollars a post per day
but if you ask them to sit down and try
and string four words together they
wouldn't be able to do it so
i i think that um there is a little bit
of uh
we're vacillating between different
extremes at the moment
um and perhaps we're seeing this
counter to the sort of enlightenment
period where you had people where
um intellect and academics were very
very tightly confined
and now it's been completely emancipated
and everyone can get access to it
and uh right okay now everyone that's
like remotely clever can be super rich
right okay now let's find somewhere
that's
that's a happy medium between the two
yeah i wonder how much
looking back this will look like a gold
rush um and i actually have the same so
i have a
huge admiration for online courses and i
think
um i have definitely spent some days
thinking about
exactly how you feel and how what you
just articulated
uh and i also think that it is
at the same time there is so much value
in them
and they can be so much more
transformative for people because
they kind of they layer in
accountability and social mechanisms and
they add some kind of
visual and audio learning that you know
people who
um don't get as much like out of a book
might resonate with
and the time that it takes um it
actually like makes you more invested
the money you invest makes you more
invested
so if you want to change who you are as
a person unless you really
have the discipline to bring your full
self to take a book and transform it
into your reality then i absolutely
believe in online course can be
incredibly valued and worth every penny
that you're paying for it
i think there's definitely the key
insight there is the fact that people
are paying for the end result
they're paying for the outcome that they
get at the end if
you would be to be able to say right you
can buy james clear's atomic habits for
10 pounds
or you can pay a thousand pounds but
you'll implement 90
of the book a lot of people would more
than happen because they're paying for
the end goal
and the the more frictionless that you
can make that and the
higher completion the higher success
rate you can make that as well
you're going to have yeah justifiably
more revenue
i think we're we just maybe crested the
hill of some innovation in those online
courses that gets
that actually makes it deliver the
result to people i think
um you know i went through this at
reforge um
which is like a silicon valley kind of
growth consulting
or growth practitioning sort of course
it's an expensive course but it is
incredible it's taught by some of the
most brilliant
kind of growth people in the valley um
you see it with
thiago forte and david perrell's courses
like they are very focused on delivering
the outcome with jack butchers
um and and that is that is very
different than like
you know that hey we recorded some
college lectures and put them online
sort of feel and these these like
artisanal like
almost kind of innovators in in courses
are
really doing some awesome stuff and
transforming lives but there's
also a whole bunch of shysters out there
to your point that are like
that people pay 200 for anything like if
i make some you know vast promises and
then i can just blame them for not
actually following through
and make a ton of money on it everyone
knows so i had
mike win it on have you seen the
entrepreneur on
youtube no oh dude you will absolutely
adore this
so um most of the people that listening
will be familiar with him british guy
he looked at the
naughty psychological tricks that are
being used by what he deems
contrapreneurs online so it's your dan
penas of this world it's the
um grant cardones and
it's um high ticket value heavily
discounted down
it's the limited time limited value
limited amount of offers
like imagine saying that there is a
limited number of an infinite product
and genuinely considering yourself to be
a legitimate businessman
like [ __ ] off and the only people that
make money from those courses the only
people who
he's ever found who've made money from
grant cardone's courses
are resellers so the only people who
make money from the course are people
reselling the course
which is a [ __ ] pyramid scheme that
is a pyramid scheme i'm aware that it's
not it's managed to subvert the
expectations of it being a pyramid
scheme
because it delivers something but when
that something is so [ __ ]
that the only thing you can make money
on is reselling more [ __ ]
like that that is what it is so yeah i
think
you know to kind of bookend the um i
have concerns over the online course
world like don't get me wrong
um the plan my main plan to
assist monetization for the podcast is
to create a partner academy
which is um the guys from podcast notes
doing summaries of
every episode uh communities similar to
jax where we can discuss about stuff
it's basically like a patreon on
steroids
with a ton of stuff that'll really help
people but i'm like right what's the
lowest entry ticket can i do it for nine
pounds a month can i can i give
all of this value for that much and will
it will it work right okay yeah great
as opposed to it being something that
costs that
literally doesn't add any value and
costs ten thousand
dollars or you know five nine nine seven
or whatever it might be so i think
yeah hopefully we will see the
resurgence in
um people becoming more savvy
to the the dick funnels approach
which has i been know if you find that
but i like it a lot
that's another that's another mike
winitism yeah he uh his next his next
episode is on
uh he's the guy behind click funnels
anyway the guy that created clickfunnels
there'll be people screaming down there
their airpods to me at the moment
um the guy that made dick funnels uh
uh that's that's actually so this is i
really want to do
um it's only a toddler right now it's
like a baby baby business
um but i want to get it going and where
i think um
there's so much to i think there's a
wave of courses coming
and especially as like actual real
school is now pretty much online now
that this like the meritocracy that we
talked about is going to move into
online courses
um and something that i'm getting going
is basically wirecutter for online
courses
um it's called course correctly oh
wirecutter's like
this very high-end review site it's for
electronics mostly
um it got acquired by the new york times
i think you're excited trust trust pilot
or trip advisor or whatever
yeah more um more like staff written
highly curated reviews okay okay yeah
yeah i'm
working out ways for people to basically
like get the course for
free and then uh write a very very
detailed review of like did it change
your life
what kind of people is it good for what
is it not what does the course promise
but not deliver on
um i've got a few reviews up on there
already but if anybody wants to like
write a review of a course that they
have been on like i'm gonna start
hosting
independent unbiased like verified
reviews for online courses
because i think it's so hard to find
anything written about things that is
not pushed out by the course creator
themselves
and so separating some of this stuff and
being like you know can you imagine
being a
24 year old kid and you're sitting there
with your life savings about to buy like
one course or the other and you're like
i don't know grant cardone here's my
advice 24 year old
do not spend your money on grant
cardone's course yeah eric man you need
to i'll
link you in with mike because what he's
doing in this space specifically he's
doing it in a very british way
which is very kind of dour and and
quite satirical um and i think sort of
dulcet but
really vicious as well and incredibly
effective
um yeah i'll link you two guys in
because you would you'd absolutely love
him and
he's a great guy how does naval suggest
that we get lucky um noval categorizes
four kinds of luck um there's just blind
luck where you just trip over it
there's hustle luck where you're having
every coffee you can find
you know this is uh i think of like gary
vee is hustle luck like
that guy little guy man but but it works
right like
there if you work hard enough you will
increase your surface area
to luck and like you will kind of find
some tailwinds um
the third is increasing your sensitivity
and so just like
getting deep enough into things and
looking for opportunities and believing
that they're there
is a huge piece of it and the fourth um
which
is beautiful and i love it is basically
become so unique
that luck becomes your destiny like when
you are the only person
who can unlock a certain opportunity or
you are so well known for a certain
thing that people just come to you for
it
um that is that is when luck becomes
your destiny that's
the fourth type of luck that is that the
most ideal the most
sought after it takes the long it takes
a long time it's the hardest to get
but understanding that it's there and
it's at the end of that road um can
really
kind of draw you along and help you
separate even as you're looking at other
people you know what kind of luck did
that person
get versus the other right what how does
warren buffett get lucky versus how does
mark cuban get lucky like
who just kind of sold at the top and who
has the sort of reputation
and um kind of uniqueness
that there's just only one person to
call and like it feels like luck when
you get the call but it's also
the end result of 50 years of hard work
when it's consistently you that's
getting the call as well
that's when i i've been trying i've been
playing around with this concept for a
little while to do with
there's a lot of people i know who are
still very successful
james smith is a good example british
guy he's like the gordon ramsay of the
pt world
so he calls out [ __ ] diets and
um ineffective training regimes and he
has a best-selling book and he's just
about to release another one they'll
almost certainly be a best-selling book
and he makes
[ __ ] money through uh his his
online academy as well and um
yeah he he has a very unique
view because his ascendance into clout
like global clout has been so quick that
he's still got a lot of latent imposter
syndrome in him he doesn't say it
but i know that it's i know that it's
there um and he's got a
a best-selling book written by him not
ghost written
written by him on an industry that he
worked in for 10 years
and he's still waking up every morning
waiting for people to rumble the fact
that he doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing
and there has to be a point for all of
us
and this is like a this is a siren song
to the grafter who's
talented but still doesn't believe in
themselves and maybe it's a
word to me myself as well that
there's only so many times that your
imposter syndrome
can clash up against reality and your
reality
annihilates your imposter syndrome
before
continuing to have imposter syndrome is
more an addiction
than it is a survival mechanism
i think a healthy amount of imposter
syndrome actually can come across as
humbleness which is really useful
um and it helps to wrangle our ego and
stop it from getting out of control
but there's an
area where you like naval is humble
because he chooses to be humble where he
needs to be
as opposed to having this false sense of
a lack of
enoughness in particular areas and
that's a very big distinction between
that
so yeah if if you're doing stuff try and
look with as much rationality and logic
as you can at the things that you've
done
and think like look am i am i
continually
beating the odds of what my own imposter
syndrome expected me to do
and if that's the case then that the um
would you say like the the window of
what imposter
where it should be needs to shift to one
way or another
and hopefully hopefully people will will
see that and if the same thing goes for
the look
if it's constantly you getting the call
over and over and over and over again
then fair play do you think there's
something that's in my head
do you think that the line from
accountability
which is skin in the game high
visibility
to this um one key one lock
solution you are the person that can fix
the the problem therefore you get look
on the route between those two things
avoiding the status seeking
avoiding the clout for clout's sake
avoiding the hierarchy games
like there's a lot of left and right
turns between that
do you think yeah i think so and i think
it's a
very good line to draw between
accountability
and and that fourth type of luck that is
the the uniqueness luck
and the you know sort of reputational
look um
i think you you get that by having you
know demonstrably good judgment and good
outcomes over a very long period of time
of accountability that's how you know
you get people that want to work for you
that's how you
get people to want to invest in you
that's how um you get people to want to
you know use your products or listen to
them or learn from them or
you know buy the tools you know that's
um
in a way that's basecamp's marketing
strategy right it's it's
when you start to see accountability um
as like the very essence of brand
building you start to see
how pervasive it is and how common it is
and how even
you know the big companies that we trust
the most we trust them because
we know the person behind them you know
it's it's not just that it's
amazon we know that that is bezos it's
not just that it's tesla we know that
it's elon musk you know
it's not just berkshire hathaway it's
buffett like we are so much more adept
at trusting people
and holding people accountable then we
are you know
just an entity just a company that is a
brand but not a
person um and i'm sure that has like a
deep kind of
social roots like that that is
evolutionary
baked into us that we know how we can
hold a person accountable as a community
but not how we can hold this this kind
of corporation accountable
that's what at its purest sense
influencer marketing was supposed to be
right like the fact that
cristiano ronaldo has 40 million
followers but real madrid only has 12.
or that elon musk has like tens of
millions of followers and
spacex and tesla got their facebooks
deleted or whatever it was that you
decided to do to the
other so like yeah people follow people
that don't follow things
moving on happiness second half of the
book naval says that happiness
is learned do you agree because most
people
would think that happiness is a state
not a skill
yeah i think that's a that's a
misconception that leaves a lot of
people unhappy
um and you you hear it in how people
talk about happiness you know
they say like did that make you happy or
i just want to make you happy
and like make you happy when you look at
those words and think about it is such a
[ __ ] up
kind of concept um and almost all
conversational relations to happiness
are about external circumstances
like are you happy you got this thing
will you be happy if you get this thing
like it's not looking at it as
not not just a choice like a choice is
is the beginning of it but a skill
right you have to choose to be happy not
just once we have to choose to learn the
skills of happiness
and over and over and over again to
pound those skills into you just like
you train like an athlete just like you
build a business like you have to put
reps into building these habits and
these perspectives of happiness
and almost making it a reflex to look at
things positively
to remember that happiness is internal
you know is derived from appreciating
what you have
from not adding new desires from not
postponing your happiness until some
accomplishment
or some you know new thing you get
um it is giving yourself permission to
be happy in this moment with what you
have and doing it
constantly and it's hard it's really
hard
and so it is not just a choice in each
moment but it is a skill
to develop the ability to keep making
that choice over and over again
how can we cultivate our happiness then
yeah
there's a lot to um there's a lot of
habits kind of listed out in the book
that that is maybe the most tactical
kind of level of it um and there's a
there's a few
um off the top of my head that like one
that stuck with me
is uh whenever you see the sun feel the
sun on your skin
like look up and smile right it's such a
small
tiny thing but like you will find a
beautiful perfect moment if you just
take a second to like
feel how good the sun feels and look up
at it and just like have this moment of
connection with like our
energy source um you know on a
like more tech level like don't set an
alarm clock
minimize your use of calendar and those
are
things those are ways that like those
are external controls of your time that
pull you out of the present moment you
know if your body needs to keep sleeping
if you don't want to get out of bed yet
like if you don't have an alarm clock
pushing you out of bed
maybe you'll be a little happier in that
moment you'll appreciate like how the
sheets feel you'll appreciate the
temperature of the room you'll take a
deep breath like keeping your mind where
you are
is is maybe and appreciating you know
the smallest thing
um this wasn't i think never retweeted
this but i don't know if it was an
original navalism but like
i i love it because it's got a perfect
trigger with a thing that i
look at every day if you can't be happy
with a cup of coffee
you won't be happy with a yacht and so i
have this this thought every time i like
pour a cup of coffee and hold this kind
of warm thing and smell it and i'm like
this is making me happy in this moment
and i know that if i can be happy with a
cup of coffee i can be happy with with
anything
that's awesome man let's talk about
desire what's the key insight to do with
desire to learn from naval
yeah we'll start with like the most
dense aphorism
which is success desire is a contract
you make
to be unhappy until you get what you
want
which is an easy thing to hear and be
like
oh okay um and a very difficult thing to
remember to apply to
everything that you desire we so
instinctively
pick up new desires so quickly um it's
just really easy to look around us and
walk through a story like i want that i
want that i want that you know to look
at other people
especially on social you know you scroll
through your instagram and in
20 minutes i'm like [ __ ] i really want
to be
a genius stand-up comedian who looks
like the rock and cooks like anthony
bourdain
and there's no reason that i shouldn't
be able to have all three
and i just decide to be unhappy until
i've accomplished
all of those goals that all those people
spend their entire lives doing in
completely different directions
um and it takes like going back to that
idea that
you don't want to make a contract with
yourself to be unhappy until you get
something especially
if it is a wildly [ __ ] unrealistic
thing to ever
to ever get um so
knowing that that you really should have
a limited number of desires like naval
says just one at a time
you know if you're gonna if you're
really focused on building your company
focus on building your company and like
allow yourself that desire
but but be contented with everything
else that you have and really work hard
to accept every other circumstance and
not
pile on you know your incredible you
know fitness goals or goals to travel
and goals to like
just take one desire at a time um and
work to minimize the rest you know it's
so much
easier it should be easier it is
definitely cheaper
to eliminate a desire than it is to
you know overspend to go into debt to to
try to like run in too many directions
at once
and those other desires are likely to
kind of cost you
more of your your energy your mojo your
focus on that one thing that you
actually most desire in prioritizing
those is is really hard
and i think um you know the younger you
are the easier it is to take on more
desires you have more possibilities in
front of you you
you have a little less um direction and
track record of like what you know you
want for
sure and so you're interested in all
these different things and you pursue
all these different things at once and
you have
this huge multitude of desire and i
think um
one of my hypotheses for this
interesting fact that like
70 year olds are usually the most happy
cohort of people
and i wonder how much of that is like
they really have learned to appreciate
what they have
they really feel comfortable with with
who they are
and they don't have a ton of desires you
know they they
are have learned the skill of
contentedness and appreciation for the
for the things that they have and
they're not constantly looking forward
to the next thing the next thing the
next thing they're just living in the
moment and enjoying you know
what who they're with and what they're
doing the problem that we come up
against here is what i brought up
earlier on
it is easier to achieve your material
desires than it is to renounce them i've
been thinking about this for
ages that the trajectory
of your particular modus operandi within
life
has already been laid out by your elders
look to your granddad look to the things
that your granddad enjoys doing you know
a a a nice glass of wine while he
watches the football on a saturday
afternoon and going to the pub with his
friends and
a walk with your grandma with the dog
and stuff like that the simple pleasures
and we
we i think can over romanticize that but
it is impossible
to pass those away from is that
only able to be achieved when you've
already gone and done the things
it's significantly easier for your next
car to be
something that some banged up family
mobile after five ferraris because
you're like do you know what it is i've
already done the ferrari thing that
doesn't really matter
and this also unfortunately ties into
one of the reasons that i think naval's
so seductive to a lot of us
that his real world success is something
that we all want to try and
emulate and achieve and the problem with
that is that
a unsuccessful version of naval
who would be able to use the desire
contract
aphorism more accurately because we
couldn't call him out for only saying
that's easy because you've achieved all
the things you want to achieve
materially
we wouldn't respect because he hadn't
actually managed to make stuff manifest
in the real world
does that make sense it does um
i don't know i'm interested i want to
push back on it a little bit because i
think
i think they like it's easier to achieve
your material successes than to
eliminate them
is maybe it's probably true for some
things but it also
kind of it doesn't take into account the
trap of the like hedonic treadmill
and so you know it maybe it's easier to
achieve
you know getting a really nice getting a
bmw but then if i have a bmw i'm going
to want a ferrari and if i have a
ferrari i'm going to want a private jet
and if i have a private jet i want a
sports team if i have a sports team i
want a [ __ ] country
like there's no reason for that to stop
and if you just let it keep snowballing
like
at some point it is easier to learn how
to
especially if you realize that the path
that you are on and that you are happy
with
is not going to lead to enormous
incredible wealth like
for plenty of people i'm sure you know
i'm a teacher i love being a teacher
i'm going to make maybe a best couple
hundred you know
tens of thousands of dollars a year like
even if i start a business on the side
i'm just never gonna buy a sports team
and that's perfectly okay
and so now i have to learn to control my
desires and and
i think that's what's so important about
this book is that it has the two halves
of happiness
are are how much you have and how much
you want
and combining those i think like uh
morgan housel on your podcast actually
did an incredible job with this he's
like
it's not about how much you make it's
not about how much you want it's about
the relationship between the two and
understanding that those levers are
connected
i don't care what your means are because
you're living below them
like you're you're going to be happy as
long as your desires are in line with
with your lifestyle and so controlling
those two things and
kind of moving them around so that you
can find yourself in a state of
happiness again like
if you're not happy with a cup of coffee
you're not going to be happy with a
yacht if you're not happy in a toyota
you won't be happy in a ferrari you're
just going to want to add the lambo like
i don't know what to tell you so
like if you don't see that if you don't
see that desire
as the source of an unhappiness um
it's going to be tough to kind of get
over that hump
uh whether you get what you want or not
because you'll just leap to the next
desire
they say that true hell is when the
person that you are meets the person
that you could have been
but it seems like in this situation it's
more like true hell
is when the person who you are imagines
all of the stuff that the person who you
could have been could have had
yeah i i think that's you know that's a
good maybe motivational quote for you
you know be all you can be um but it
also is the sort of mental trap that can
leave you like
deeply unhappy if you imagine you know
what would have gone
how your life would have been if
everything would have worked out
perfectly and
you had gotten lucky at every turn and
worked your face off at every single
thing like that that's a recipe for
misery i agree but is that not just due
to most people
having a misaligned idea of what their
full potential could be
if you were to fully imbibe the naval
philosophy
then your full potential would be
someone who is as actualized and present
and happy with as little as possible
so conver in a bizarre way you would
almost
be upset at your own level of
materialism
so the materialism itself would be the
thing that you say my potential is to
have less materialism than this
not more stuff yeah i think that's um
you know separating materialism
from your accomplishments and your your
contentedness
you know your inner state from your
outer state um because it's it's
difficult to
imagine a maximalized version of both of
those kind of as coexisting i think
um naval's like nuance here which i
think is interesting is he
he doesn't want to be the most
successful version of himself
he wants to be the one that is
statistically likely to become
the most successful and so it it's a
little like if there's
if there's a thousand of all in a
thousand different universes he wants to
live his life and
build his businesses in such a way that
999 of those thousand eventually become
successful
you know if you go to the casino
and put it all on double zero over and
over and over and over again and
10 million people are able to do it one
of those guys is going to get incredibly
successful
you know just to use a very simplified
metaphor
but most of those people and those
people on average are going to get
decimated and be unhappy
and so his kind of mo around
how he makes his decisions and how he
kind of architects his life it's like i
don't want to work as hard as possible i
don't want to be as successful the most
successful version of myself
i want to do the things that allow me to
get kind of the most
successful with the least risk the least
variance and the least um actually the
least
input like i want the highest ratio of
of input to output that i can get i
don't want to spend my life working is
what he would say like
he loves what he does now he loves
starting businesses and investing and
does it continues to do it as an art
form as i don't want to
you know spend 20 hours a day working
doing things that i don't necessarily
want to do in order to achieve some
outcome
um but finding a thing that he loves to
do and doing it in a way that
statistically across a wide set of his
lives if you were to play them out you
know on a monte carlo
simulation would very often or most
often
lead to some level some outlier level of
success but not
an extreme outlier he's not willing to
take huge huge downside risk in order to
get that extreme
stream outside i think that's a lovely
antithesis to the hustle and grind
mentality that i think a lot of people
can fall down the trap of and we all do
as well it's sad
and unfortunate that the thing which
often sets us apart in our 20s and 30s
is the thing that we need to try and
cast away and lose as an attachment in
our 40s and 50s
like you there's there's a period where
you've got to get your nose and stick it
on the grindstone for a long time
you need to grind away on your craft
whether that be learning the skills that
you can leverage later in life
building up the authenticity and the
amount of clout and notoriety that you
have within an industry
even if that's as fully and beautifully
aligned and actualized as we've been
talking about here with all of the
requisite
um amounts of presentness you can't get
around the
fact that it's a function of intensity
times time
the cal newport work done uh equation
if you do more work if you outwork
everyone at a higher intensity then you
piss all over them and that's the way
that's the way that it works um but yeah
i i really do think that that
antithesis to the hustle and grind
mentality is super important i think
it's really really
nice for people to to understand and as
well
this is coming from someone that we both
believe is incredibly wise that he
enjoys as does buffett as does
monger a life that is
driven by ridiculous amounts of freedom
and the only reason that they look like
they're working all the time is that
that's what they choose to do
morgan housel's definition of what
wealth gets you
is wealth allows you to do what you want
when you want with who you want for as
long as you want and no one gets to tell
you otherwise
that is what wealth allows you to do and
that level of freedom is something that
i think
maximally we can all aspire to and you
can get there in multiple different ways
you can get there by reducing down the
material desire because if you reduce
down the threshold at which materially
you will be happy
then you can afford to work less to get
there which means that you have more
time to spend on
stuff not just stuff that you have to do
but stuff that you get to do
and then if you can use the leverage and
all of the other tools to
free yourself liberate yourself from
sort of the typical rat race
then you also get to be able to do what
you want to do all the time because work
is the thing that you get to choose
because you've defined it yourself
yeah and i think this is um sort of a
kind of
to take the side road here i don't know
if you have studied the kind of
financial independent
early retirement movement at all no i've
seen it i've seen it online
it's a it's a really interesting um you
know if people are asking
the question now of kind of like okay
how do you work on that skill of living
below your means and understanding like
getting a big gap between what you're
earning and what you're spending and
finding fulfillment and things that
don't
that aren't hugely costly um reducing
your material desires
that is kind of a i don't know there's
uh reddits on it
there are the book that's kind of the
forefather of this is early retirement
extreme
by jacob fisker it's a it's a nutcase
book
um but it is like so extreme that when
you dial that back to like a normal
person you still end up way way ahead of
most people
um the blog that kind of pulled me down
this is um mr money mustache
it's a great blog he's a hilarious guy
and he was a software engineer for like
10 years got his personal savings rate i
think to like
60 or 70 percent and it's this idea that
like
you're living on you know if you're
making 80 000 a year you're living on 30
000
a year yourself a family so you know
taking walks you just
either only have one car and barely use
it you mostly ride bikes you know
you play board games brew your own beer
if you want to
have picnics instead of going out to 100
dinners you know like
there are ways to live a very happy and
fulfilling life on
not that much money that is not
correlated at all with increased
material possessions and he worked for
10 years as a software engineer
and built up enough net worth through
his savings and his investments
that he retired so he retired at 30 or
31
and he's like i can live for the rest of
my life very happily on
what i have saved up and he continues to
work he continues to kind of
do things that he wants to do but it is
that perfect freedom there's a lot of
paths to that freedom is kind of like
the point of bringing up this other
movement
you can try to work really hard and earn
a ton of money so that like you no
matter what your desires are you can
never outspend them
you can go you know be a monk or and
that kind of like
you know middle ground for middle class
with normal jobs
is is really well explored i think in
this kind of financial independence
early retirement
um movement so i encourage people to go
like check that out and go down that
rabbit hole if that's something that
they're interested in
that's really cool i've heard of him
before but i've never read i've never
read any of his stuff
just the name i wanted i want to see the
man the
mustache that's what i want to see yeah
he has great fun with it he's just
ruthlessly mocking people with expensive
cars and
you know unnecessary possessions and
things that people think are going to
lead to happiness but aren't
um and he made a hilarious character out
of it and of course because he was
you know using his specific knowledge
and accountability and leverage
he built this incredible blog that makes
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
and so
he could have retired off that and and
desperately trying to give his money
away yeah because he was doing something
that was fun to him and totally
authentic and he did it with a lot of
energy
and a lot of people kind of uh got
excited about it and fell in with him
um i think it's another incredible
example of productizing yourself and he
did that
accidentally you know with no intention
really whatsoever
what are three insights or quotes from
naval which have had the biggest impact
on how you operate in the world
if you do a top of the pops
run down of the the the three most
insightful quotes are the ones that have
had the biggest impact on you
yeah i can't promise i'll do these word
for word but i'll try um
i think the one that's been sitting on
top of my head the most is is just
this idea that we are here for such a
short amount of time
in the grand scheme of the universe and
we are entirely in control of our
perception
of the things that are happening to us
and and here's the key piece is that any
moment that you are not
happy that you're not choosing to
interpret what's happening to you
positively
you're not doing anyone any favors you
are not better off for being unhappy
the people around you aren't better off
for you being unhappy
i think i i don't exactly know where it
comes from but we certainly have this
um this thing built into us that we feel
like we are not supposed to
feel happy we're not supposed to allow
ourselves to feel happiness until we've
accomplished something until we've
delivered some results whether it's for
ourselves or for
someone else or our employer for our
partner for our family
um and that it is possible to
kind of allow yourself happiness and to
make progress at the same time
like i don't know if if other that is as
hard for other people as it is for me
um and maybe that's like the athlete in
me that came from you know like
you just gotta like put your eyebrows
down and and put your back into it and
like strength comes from that and like
that will push you harder
um and artists may be better at kind of
feeling flow and creativity in the
moment and feeling like they have to be
happy in order to work instead of being
unhappy in order to prevail
um but i think that's that's a really
interesting idea um
on the wealth side just the fact that
you have to build or buy equity in a
business
um that really i realize
when you put that at the forefront um
there's a lot of ways to do it right you
know i was kind of raised with the like
work hard get a good job put it on a
retirement account a 401k
index it you know the jack bogle
playbook and
that is a way to build equity in a
business like when you buy into the
stock market
you're you that is a you know you're
buying a ton of different businesses and
allowing that to compound and pay
dividends for you
um there is also the small business
world where we are all
basically a small business of one we own
100 of the shares
and whether or not you're going to go do
something with that to make that
more valuable um in the silicon valley
world you've got
you know take a job with stock options
and you try to kind of
work your way into companies that are
going to be valuable and positions that
are higher up so you get more stock
options and that is a way to builder buy
equity in a company
um you know there's a lot of ways to
accomplish that when you see that as the
goal
um but but understanding that that is a
goal not necessarily just a higher
hourly income
or something like that um those are kind
of you know maybe one from each world
that are
they're sitting with me right now have
you got a third one have you got
anything else that you've
come across from him recently that you
think is uh is maybe a little bit
different
this one um isn't talked about very much
i don't think um i don't think naval is
necessarily thought of as as like funny
and charismatic as as i think
he is um you know he's introverted he
doesn't do a ton of talks or anything
like that
but there is one um that uh
charisma is the ability to be both
positive
and uh or to project love and positivity
kind of at the same time or honesty
sorry the charisma is the ability to
project honesty and positivity at the
same time
and that is almost always possible right
so you don't have to tell someone harsh
truths about themselves
you don't have to present the truth in a
negative contradictory
harsh fashion and i think that is
somewhat in vogue right there's always
the character who's like delivering
harsh truths
um you know and like thought of as smart
and competent because they're able to
like pop people's bubble
and that just people don't like that um
you know
it plays well on tv and it's it's maybe
like funny to watch
but if you take that character take that
as your character into real life like
it's gonna be really hard to build
positive relationships and to
um kind of work smoothly with other
people so
um projecting honesty
and positivity at the same time is
something that um
certainly i'm working on and it's
certainly tied with the like
there's no reason not to be happy with
each individual moment you're not doing
anyone any favors by being negative
and you can be positive and honest at
the same time i think this is one of the
problems i have with the
like meninism men's rights
red pill movement overall that the vast
vast vast majority
of the guys that fly that flag super
hard just sound like bitter old men
i'm like bro like i don't want to be you
i don't want to be you
there's a part of every guy that even if
it would do your head in wants to know
what it would be like to be dan
bilzerian for a day
but like dan is i think probably failure
not in his business dealings actually
he's about to go bust but um at least
with the way that he puts himself across
he's fairly honest
and he's positive you know like it's got
to be positive to scam
people out of 20 million dollars for a
cbd company or whatever it is that he's
been doing
i am not like i'm gonna have to get some
lawyers or something to protect me so if
you can
if you have if you can help me at the
end of this podcast that'll be wonderful
um i've been thinking
about there was something that you just
brought up there which is that naval
doesn't do a ton of talks
about his brother kamal on um i've
tweeted him incessantly that's a lie
i've tweeted him a couple of times about
it
um but i know that he's basically on
apart from his own stuff he's basically
on a sabbatical
um from doing sort of press ever since
the rogan episode
and i wonder whether
he realizes how
smart of a tactic that is to reduce
the supply of naval so that the demand
continues to skyrocket and that the
amount
of the the value per minute of the stuff
that he does choose to put out continues
to go up
yeah i don't know how deliberate it is
um
but i mean you can see in in everything
that he does is a very high
quality bar and and has
you know he's not building a media
company he's doing this for us i think
you know more
more than himself all he's doing really
here is kind of like
learning in public and giving back a
little bit and um
yeah i i'm you know we're lucky he does
as much as he does i think
um there's there's i think plenty of
people who are
equally or more successful that don't do
nearly as much kind of
teaching and giving and sharing of their
perspectives as he does
um and as you know i've benefited a lot
from from what he shared and
i wish more people would kind of take
the time to do it um
ray dalio you know i know there's
there's a chapter of careers where
people kind of turn to that
that piece um but it's hard work you
know it's it's a lot of effort to
distill what you've done and you know i
know ray dalio put
many many hours of effort into into
principles both for his business and
and for the book um you know i know
naval certainly put work into the
podcast and the tweet storm and and
things like that
um but then that's what was kind of
fulfilling about this project is that i
got to
manifest a thing that i wanted like i
wanted neval to write a book
um and just realizing that all of the
raw material was out there and that i
could
do the work for him um knowing that i
didn't think he probably ever was and he
was fine with it
um so this is this is fulfilling to kind
of see this come to life i really wanted
to
the principles of naval and and this is
kind of what it turned into
i bet it was man like create the podcast
that you wanted to listen to write the
book that you wanted to read build the
product that you would have bought
it's such an easy way to ensure that you
continue to build
things that are aligned with your
interests and that other people like
if you think that it's a good idea well
the people
probably think it's a good idea you've
got you know two arms and two legs and a
brain and a set of eyes and stuff you
know you are you are
a common denominator for the rest of us
so before we finish up man final
question
what do you disagree most with naval on
hmm yeah that's a good question um
i don't i don't know
that um we talked about this a little
bit i think um
earlier on i don't know how compatible
the kind of like iron prescription
stoic philosophy is with with super
close
kind of intimate like family
relationships
um and there's a little bit of kind of
breadcrumbs around that but he never
really speaks directly to like
how um how he practices these principles
kind of with
his wife or with um you know children or
anything like that
and i'm really um that is that is one of
the like toughest tests i think of a
philosophy is is
when the relationships matter most these
people close to you who
you know their emotions matter to you
and their their pain hurts you and their
happiness
you know affects your happiness like
how do you how strict of a prescription
is the stoicism
in in those sorts of things um is
something that i'm really
i don't know if i disagree with it
because i don't know what he thinks
about it but i'm
i'm interested in the practicalities of
that piece
for sure there's all different areas we
said right at the very beginning that
one of the reasons both of us are drawn
to naval is that he's not armchair
philosophizing
about this stuff it's even beyond
philosophy designed for practicality
it's philosophy forged in reality
and i think the fact that we have that
is something that's so great
but there are a few
very hot forges that challenge
people in ways beyond the normal
comfort zone you know like when you talk
about
deeply embedded self-beliefs from when
you are a child
the source code of like who you think
you are that's one of them
you know your your family relationships
how are you and your significant other
and any children that you may have how
are you managing
four hours of sleep a night with a
newborn baby for
for six months you know in a
relationship where blah blah blah blah
blah blah like add on a bunch more
stress like that's that's real for
because we can sit here and talk about
the business does it this thing and blah
blah but you don't go home to the
business
you know the business the business isn't
lying in bed scowling at you at night it
might not it might feel like that from
the way that you're in a monologue talks
to you but there's always a particular
level of detachment and i think the way
that the narrative always is and also
the way that we feel it should be
is that there is a particular safety
around certain things in life there's a
home base that is insulated from the
chaos of the outside world
family being one of them and even
further internally than that the inner
monologue and the way that you see
yourself
um so yeah i think hopefully
after his little sabbatical naval will
come out of his
hiding hole and decide that he's gonna
unleash a whole more stuff on us because
i mean
got that that joe rogan podcast if you
want the best overview i think that you
can get before you decide to
read the navalmonac um i think go and
listen to
naval on joe rogan it'll be linked in
the show notes below uh as will
the almanac of naval rava can't why
should people go they want to check out
and read all the extra materials and
and get the full eric jorgensen
experience where do they
yeah go nevalbanac.com um is the
the site up for the book so we've got ac
right
yeah yeah n-a-v-a-l i can't spell it
yeah you'll figure it out yeah link
below just press the link
press the link it's linked from my
twitter which is
at eric jorgensen um i do a little bit
of writing on ejorgensen.com
um but i've got open dms and emails i'm
easy to find
i'm definitely gonna keep updating
things on the email list for the book
website so we'll keep having kind of
new material new explorations i'll
update things as novel comes out with
more stuff
i'm really interested to kind of dive
deeper into exploring leverage
and uh seeing kind of more of those
applications and i'm thinking about
doing some like
case studies of of applying the
principles from the book into how
different people have built their
businesses um so i feel like you know
the book is out but we are still like
there's a lot more to explore and a lot
of interesting stuff to do like around
the book and and like with the community
um there's a there's a chapter in the
book that's the whole um
section of naval's recommended reading
and i thought it'd be super interesting
to do like a
like a reading group around it like a
study group for some of those materials
um for people who want to kind of get
into the influences and the sources
um yeah i think it'll be really fun
there's a lot of
there's a lot of good ideas floating
around um if you got ideas
like i said dm me email me i'm open i'd
love to hear i love it man thank you
so much for coming on everything that
we've spoken about including the almanac
of naval ravican
eric's twitter his website everything
will be linked in the show notes below
um i hope that naval's ears haven't
melted his airpods as we've said his
name about 45 000 times
or if you want to party and you're in
lockdown listen to this podcast again
and take a shot every time that we say
the word naval
um because that would be we're we are
not liable for you're
definitely going to die yeah yeah 100
eric man it's been awesome thank you so
much for coming on
yeah super fun thanks
you